du jour appelle la question orale de
monsieur christian cambon à monsieur
mise de l'intérieur
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre ma question s'adresse au
ministre de l'intérieur et vise à
contester la légalité d'une décision du
conseil de paris mois de février qui
stipulait que il devait être procédé à
l'installation d'une aire des gens du
voyage sur le bois de vincennes dans son
extrémité est il n'est pas ici question
de contester la nécessité républicaine
qu'on l'ensemble des maires a organisé
l'accueil des gens du voyage en revanche
la loi du 5 juillet 2000 prévoit un
certain nombre de conditions qui en
l'occurrence ne nous semble absolument
pas remplies en effet cette loi prévoit
que les aires d'installation des gens du
voyage doivent leur permettre de
faciliter la scolarisation des enfants
la proximité d'un hôpital pour leur
offrir des soins et la proximité de
centres économiques pour tenter de les
intégrer au développement de la vie
économique et sociale de notre pays en
l'occurrence le site qui a été choisie à
l'extrémité du bois de vincennes se
trouve à plus de 5 km de la première
école à paris 12e rue de charenton et
donc ce ski ceci signifie que il va
falloir transportés par navettes tous
les matins et tous les soirs les enfants
des gens du voyage pour les scolariser
dans le 12e arrondissement de paris
c'est à dire traverser les très nombreux
embouteillages qui malheureusement
bloquent l'entrée de paris dans cette
banlieue est particulièrement chargé par
ailleurs il y a bien évidemment dans le
bois de vincennes aucune installation
hospitalière aucun centre de soins et la
plus proche installations sur toit à
l'hôpital rothschild qui est lui aussi à
plusieurs kilomètres
l'ensemble des communes riveraines du
bois de vincennes s'est mobilisée elle
s'est mobilisée parce qu'avec la ville
de paris nous avions signé la main sur
le coeur une charte de protection du
bois de vincennes avec monsieur delanoë
la charte n'a jamais donné beaucoup
d'effet elle ne sait le son comité de
direction ne s'est jamais réalisé denis
depuis plus de dix ans et on s'aperçoit
qu'il y à là la volonté de faire en
sorte de renvoyer à proximité des
communes riveraines du bois de vincennes
une obligation qui incombe à la ville de
paris je rappelle que la ville de paris
possède sur son territoire des dizaines
et des dizaines pour ne pas dire des
centaines d'hectares disponibles je
pense notamment aux batignolles ou plus
de 77 hectares sont déjà disponibles la
ville de paris pouvait faire
différemment je vous le dit monsieur le
ministre le bois de vincennes comme le
bois de boulogne du reste doivent être
intégralement conservée pour le plein
air les activités de loisirs les sports
de plein air une pétition qui a été
lancée il ya quelques semaines a déjà
lancé à déjà réuni plus de dix mille
signataires de genre de toute
sensibilité qui disent laissez le bois
de vincennes cessé de lui transférer
toutes les activités dont vous ne voulez
pas on a déjà la foire du trône sur 15
hectares on a le centre de rétention des
personnes immigrantes situation
irrégulière nous avons des constructions
pour des salons etc etc je pense que la
majorité de la ville de paris et le
ministère devrait revoir cette décision
car la légalité de cette loi n'est pas
respectée et nous comptons bien
évidemment sur les éléments que vous
allez nous donner pour appuyer le
recours que du reste nous avons présenté
au nom de toutes les communes riveraines
devant le tribunal administratif de
paris jour merci merci chers collègues
la parole était monsieur benoît hamon
mini chargé de l'économie sociale et
solidaire et de la consommation merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur christian cambon
la loi donc du 5 juillet 2000 relative à
l'accueil et à l'habitat des gens du
voyage fixe comme vous l'avez indiqué
les dispositions applicables en matière
de stationnement des gens du voyage dont
l'habitat traditionnel est constitué de
résidences mobiles
l'objectif de ce texte est là encore et
je ne vous apprends rien d'établir un
équilibre entre d'une part la liberté
d'aller et venir et l'aspiration des
gens du voyage à pouvoir statique né
dans des conditions décentes et d'autre
part le souci des élus locaux d'éviter
des installations illicites susceptible
de porter atteinte au droit de la
propriété et de troubler l'ordre public
il appartient donc aux collectivités
locales de réaliser des aires d'accueil
obligations légales formalisé dans le
schéma départemental d'accueil des gens
du voyage qui constitue le pivot du
dispositif
à cet égard à la création d'un une aire
d'accueil pour les gens du voyage dans
le bois de vincennes par la commune de
paris s'inscrit dans le cadre des
obligations mises à la charge des
communes de réaliser des aires d'accueil
la délibération évoqué adoptée par le
conseil de paris dans sa séance des 11
et 12 février 2013 a été contrôlé par
les services de la préfecture de paris
elle n'a donné lieu à aucune observation
au titre de sa légalité cette
délibération a été adoptée dans la forme
requise et les textes visés dont la loi
du 5 juillet 2000 que vous évoquez qu'on
était à nos yeux correctement appliquée
la question centrale de votre
intervention concerne la localisation
d'une aire d'accueil dont le bois de
vincennes et les gènes qu'elle pourrait
occasionner comme vous l'avez un vide
évoquée c'est une question là encore à
nos yeux d'opportunités qui ne relève
pas du contrôle de légalité le bois de
vincennes fait partie du territoire
parisien ce site figure dans le schéma
départemental d'accueil des gens du
voyage et la mairie de paris a prévu un
investissement conséquent 4,8 millions
d'euros pour l'aménager l'air d'accueil
du bois de vincennes situé dans l'est
parisien permettraient un accès aisé aux
services urbains notamment les
équipements scolaires éducatifs
sanitaires sociaux et culturels ainsi
qu'aux différents services spécialisés
un réseau de transports en commun bus
métro et rer permettra aux enfants de
rejoindre les écoles de la ville de
paris dans lesquelles ils seront
scolarisés pour ce qui concerne les
prestations sociales celles ci seront
versés soit par la commune de
rattachement à en application des
articles 7 et suivants de la loi du 3
janvier 69 relatifs à l'exercice des
activités ambulantes et au régime
applicable aux personnes circulant en
france sans domicile ni résidence fixe
soit par le centre communal d'action
sociale dans le ressort territorial
duquel sont installés les demandeurs et
comme une riveraine ne seront donc
concernés par le versement de ce type de
prestation merci merci monsieur ministre
parrain et aux messieurs christian
cambon
oui merci monsieur le ministre de la
réponse tout à fait administratives et
factuelle que vous m'adressez je suis
désolé qu'on vous ait fait dire un
certain nombre de choses inexactes
vous dites en ce qui concerne vous
évoquez la régularité de la procédure je
vous rappelle que quand même la
commission nationale de protection des
sites et de l'environnement a rendu un
avis défavorable à l'unanimité à
l'unanimité alors si cette institution
nationale convoquée par le ministre et
d'où nous demandons la reconvocation
auprès de madame bateau si son avis ne
compte pour rien évidemment c'est un ou
une autre histoire par ailleurs vous
évoquez la proximité de transport en
commun je vous invite monsieur le
ministre un voyage d'étude qui n'ira pas
très loin qui vous permettra de concept
de constater qu'il n'y a strictement
aucun transport en commun à proximité ce
sont donc un système de navettes je
pense que vous n'avez jamais été même je
pense que si ça vous était arrivé je
pense que vous auriez eu beaucoup de
difficulté à expliquer à votre
population que vous envoyer les enfants
à plus de 5 km en région parisienne le
matin et le soir à l'heure des
embouteillages je pense que
véritablement c'est faire une action
sociale à peu de frais aux dépens des
autres pour se donner bonne conscience
mais monsieur le maire de paris ne s'en
sortira pas ainsi puisque le ministère
de l'intérieur semble en rester à la
légalité de la décision et bien cette
décision nous allons continuer à la
contester et à mobiliser et à mobiliser
l'opinion qui massivement et en
provenance y compris de toute la france
qui constate que l'on touche une
nouvelle fois à ses bois et on en fait
de véritables sites où l'on y installe
tout ce que l'on ne veut pas dans le
coeur de la ville eh bien il va falloir
à l'image de ce que fait long de ce que
fait new york de ce que font les grandes
capitales et alors que paris manque
singulièrement des espaces verts nous
allons nous battre pour rendre les
espaces verts au parisien